[Music]
Admiral on the bridge and captain on the
bridge
probably find this inspection boring for
the likes of YouTube boring well we
won't be blowing things up
taking your engaging in fire
Crash Landing expectedly or unexpectedly
those were the days
there is something coming
some kind of attack
and Starfleet could be the target
there's a Darkness
I'll consume in darkness
and it is getting stronger
Trust no one
[Music]
picker
we will have dangerous
you and I have traveled to the far
reaches of space
but something's different now
this is the end my friend
[Music]
Jordy
such a pathetic old Warriors
[Music]
I too was once irrational violent
is anybody you know still the person you
knew
[Music]
this is life or death it's always life
or death John Luke when has it not been
is each ticking moment I will take
another piece of view Battle Stations
survival
human nature battle
we fight or we die
I need you
all of you
we're with you
always engage
[Music]
well are you enjoying this of course not
are you